republican lawmakers also lashing out
against what some call the
woke u.s military now yesterday the
nation's top defense officials were
questioned about
diversity and extremism training that
critics say is too biased
to woke national security correspondent
jennifer griffin
takes a look tonight from the pentagon
do you believe that any member of the
military should be treated differently
based on their skin color and sex
yes or no will do no i do not believe
that and that is that is
why we have diversity equity and
inclusion focus
in the military it was supposed to be a
budget hearing instead republicans
confronted defense secretary lloyd
austin about extremism and diversity
training in the military post
january 6. senator tom cotton a former
army captain
said he and congressman dan crenshaw a
former navy seal have received several
hundred messages from service members
concerned about
what some are calling the new woke
military one marine told us that a
military history training session was
replaced with mandatory training on
police brutality white privilege and
systemic
racism a midshipman at the naval academy
said classmates are calling america a
fundamentally racist
place an airman told us their unit was
forced into a racist exercise called a
privilege walk there's things like white
privileged walks
so take two steps forward if you're
white a step back if you're black
tell me how that's inclusive tell me how
that doesn't
create divisions within our military
austin who was born
in alabama and is the first black
defense secretary
defended the military's diversity
training saying it is needed to instill
cohesion and ensure the military is
recruiting from a diverse pool of talent
that reflects america
do you believe that our military is a
fundamentally racist organization
yes or no please well i won't give you a
yes or no answer on that senator because
it deserves more than a yes or no i do
not believe it is a fundamentally racist
organization thank you i'm sorry to
catch you i'm sorry to catch you on i'm
glad that you agree
it is not fundamentally racist i don't
want our force or anybody else in this
country to be confused
it is the most lethal organization on
the face of the planet
and it will remain so and it will remain
the most cohesive
organization on the face of the planet
the pentagon is also taking heat from
the left
who want to see the pride flag displayed
at military bases
a trump year a decision that defense
secretary lloyd austin
decided recently to uphold brett
jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thanks hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else